after much teasing 20th Century Fox has
released the first trailer for the
Assassin's Creed movie but will it break
the curse of bad game two movie
adaptations I'm Lucy and welcome to your
leap of faith gamespot news update the
footage shows scenes from a present-day
setting as well as glimpses at 15th
century Spain several action scenes are
also featured and we also see a new take
on the animus farther than sitting in a
lounge chair experiencing the past
whoever uses the animus now jumps around
a big room on a harness looking kind of
like Doc Ock from spider-man Assassin's
Creed will be released in December it
stars Michael for Sasson bender who
plays two roles Callum Lynch and his
15th century Spanish assassin ancestor
iguala try saying that three times fast
the film is directed by Justin Kurt cyl
who directed the critically acclaimed
2015 film Macbeth marion cotillard
brendan gleeson michael kenneth williams
and jeremy irons are also appearing
earlier this year ubisoft announced it
was making a VR experience for the
upcoming Assassin's Creed movie no firm
details have been released but it is
being made alongside the movie Ubisoft
and Fox are reportedly already planning
a sequel to the film with Fassbender
said to be coming back so did you enjoy
the trailer does the movie look to be a
promising adaptation of the assassins
creed series let me know in the comments
below or come by me on Twitter I'm at
Lucy James games for morph Assassin's
Creed keep it gamespot
you